S
WAYS TO CENSOR CONSERVATIVES
AFTER LOSING THEIR GRIP ON
TWITTER.
THE LIBS PUSH A NARRATIVE OUT
THERE.
IT TURNS OUT TO BE CRAP,
GARBAGE, FALSE, FAKE, AND THEN
THEY BACK OFF AND PRETEND IT
DIDN'T HAPPEN AT ALL.
THEY DIE IN A MOVIE AND THEY
WANT TO MAKE MONEY ON A MOVIE.
SO THEY ARE IN THE NEXT MOVIE.
LIBERAL DUNCES ARE OUT THERE
ASKING YOU TO BELIEVE A LOT OF
GARBAGE JUNK.
FIRST TO VOTE DEMOCRAT IN JUST A
FEW DAYS YOU WOULD HAVE TO
BELIEVE ANY MID-TERM CANDIDATE
WHO IS TOUCH ON CRIME IS JUST
RACIST.
YOU KNEW THEY WERE GOING TO
THROW THAT ONE OUT THERE.
THE LIBERAL MEDIA IS MAKING THE
CASE.
BUT WHEN THE UNSPEAKABLE HAPPENS
LIKE PAUL PELOSI GETTING
ATTACKED.
SUDDENLY EVERYONE CAN GET BEHIND
THE TOUGH ON CRIME NARRATIVE.
YOU HAVE TO BELIEVE DEMOCRATS
HAVE BEEN IN CONTROL OF THE
INFLATION CRISIS FROM THE
BEGINNING.
FIRST REMEMBER INFLATION WASN'T
GOING TO HAPPEN.
THEN IT WAS TRANSITORY, THEN IT
WAS A GOOD THING.
NOW OUR ECONOMY IS STRONG AS
HELL AND THEY SAW THIS COMING
THE WHOLE TIME.
>> I AM CON CONCERNED ABOUT THE
REST OF THE WORLD.
OUR ECONOMY IS STRONG AS HELL.
>> ALL OF US KNEW THIS WOULD BE
THE CASE WHEN WE PUT IN PLACE
THIS RECOVERY PROGRAM.
DAN: HE'S SAYING THE ECONOMY
STRONG AS HELL DOESN'T MAKE THE
ECONOMY STRONG AS HELL OR STRONG
AT ALL.
BUT IN ORDER TO VOTE DEMOCRAT
YOU HAVE TO BELIEVE IN DESPERATE
MINDS.
VOTERS WOULD ALSO HAVE TO
BELIEVE CONSERVATIVES ARE
SUPPRESSING THE VOTE.
AND BY THE WAY, IT'S RACIST,
TOO.
SUGGESTING BLACK PEOPLE DON'T
KNOW HOW TO GET VOTER I.D., IT'S
HARD RACISM, LEFTY.
THAT'S A -- A FACT.
VOTERS IN GEORGIA ARE TURNING
OUT IN RECORD NUMBERS.
I THOUGHT THEY WERE BEING
SUPPRESSED.
THIS IS WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE WHEN
EVIDENCE DOESN'T.
>> OF COURSE HIGH TURNOUT AND
VOTER SUPPRESSION CAN TAKE PLACE
AT THE SAME TIME.
THEY DON'T -- ONE DOESN'T HAVE
TO HAPPEN ON ITS OWN.
DAN: HUH?
WHAT THE HELL DID SHE JUST SAY?
EVIDENCE OF VOTER SUPPRESSION IS
WHEN VOTERS TURN OUT IN RECORD
NUMBERS?
WHO IS BEING SUPPRESSED?
JUST A QUESTION FOR KARINE  *.
JUST ONE, IS ANYBODY GOING TO
ASK HER THAT QUESTION?
WE'LL JOIN ARMS ON MY FOX NEWS
SHOW IF THAT PERSON WAS
PREVENTED FROM LEGALLY VOTING.
THAT IS WORLD CLASS BULL RIGHT
THERE.
SADLY SOME DEMOCRAT VOTERS ARE
ACTUALLY BUYING IT.
THEY ARE GAS LIT SO EASILY.
HERE IS ANOTHER ITEM ON MY LIST
OF DOPEY THINGS VOTERS WOULD
HAVE TO BELIEVE TO VOTE
DEMOCRAT.
ONE OF THEM IS THAT THE LEFT
DOESN'T WANT TO DEFUND THE
POLICE.
NO NO, THEY NEVER SAID THAT.
CHECK THIS OUT.
>> I DON'T KNOW ANYBODY WHO
THINKS WE SHOULD DEFUND THE
POLICE.
>> REALLY?
THAT'S CRAZY.
I REMEMBER PROTESTS AND RIOTS
ABOUT DEFUNDING THE POLICE.
HERE IS A QUICK REFRESHER FROM
SOME OF KEITH ELLISON'S CLOSEST
DEMOCRAT FRIENDS.
>> WE NEED TO COMPLETELY
DISMANTLE THE INDIANAPOLIS
POLICE DEPARTMENT.
>> WE HAVE TO SAY REALLOCATE,
DIVEST.
BUT IT'S STILL THE SAME THING.
WE CAN'T GET CAUGHT UP ON THE
WORDS.
>> WE ARE CONSERVATIVE SO WE ARE
GOOD AT REMEMBERING STUFF.
THE DEMOCRAT VOTERS JUST
FOLLOW -- THEY LICK THEIR FINGER
AND SAY WHERE IS THE WIND
BLOWING NOW.
>> NO DEMOCRAT LEFTIST EVER SAID
THIS.
>> A VACCINATED OPINION GETS
EXPOSED TO THE VIRUS, THE VIRUS
DOES NOT INFECT THEM, THE VIRUS
CANNOT THEN USE THAT BERN TO GO
ANYWHERE ELSE.
>> YOU ARE NOT GOING TO GET
COVID IF YOU HAVE THE
VACCINATION.
DAN: A PFIZER OFFICIAL ADMITTED
THEY NEVER TESTED THE
VACCINATION.
EVERY SINGLE PARENT MEMBERS SAY
THEIR CHILDREN WERE FORCED OUT
OF SCHOOL DURING THE PANDEMIC
AND THE LEFT MADE THE KIDS GET
THE JAB AND WEAR THE FACEMASK
BEFORE THEY COULD RETURN.
JUST PRETEND IT WAS A GHOST
STORY AND IT WANTS THAT BAD.
>> SHE SAYS I KEPT KIDS OUT
LONGER THAN ANY OTHER STATE.
THAT'S NOT TRUE.
KIDS WERE OUT THREE MONTHS.
DAN: WHAT DO YOU THINK YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT?
SOME OF THESE KIDS WERE OUT FOR
A YEAR.
WHO IS THAT KID IN MY KITCHEN.
THAT LOOKS LIKE BOBBY OUR SON.
WHAT THE HELL IS HE DOING HERE?
GRETCHEN WHITMER SAYS HE'S IN
SCHOOL.
RUNNING FOR GOVERNOR IN
MICHIGAN.
WHAT A TRAIN WRECK.
THIS IS A MASSIVE MISDIRECTION
ATTEMPT.
THIS ADMINISTRATION IS TRYING TO
MAKE YOU FORGET ABOUT ALL THIS.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT THEY REALLY
WANT TO TALK ABOUT?
NUCLEAR WAR, UKRAINE, INFLATION?
ELECTRIC SCHOOL BUSES AND RACIST
LEG ROOM ON AIRPLANES.
>> WHEN I THINK ABOUT WHAT THE
EXPERIENCE SHOULD BE FOR OUR
CHILDREN OF GOING TO SCHOOL ON
THE SCHOOL BUS, UNDERSTANDING
THAT THIS BUS SYMBOLIZES SO MUCH
ABOUT OUR COLLECTIVE INVESTMENT
IN OUR FUTURE.
>> SOME AIRLINES IF YOU WANT SIX
MORE INCHES BETWEEN YOU AND THE
SEAT IN FRONT, YOU PAY MORE
MONEY.
THESE ARE JUNK FEES AND THEY HIT
LOW INCOME FOLKS AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR THE HARDEST.
DAN: THE ON THING THAT CAN SAVE
THEM IS SOME HARD-CORE GAS
LIGHTING AND GETTING VOTERS TO
BELIEVE THEIR GHOST STORIES